what's your greatest Pinch Me moment
that you're like I can't I love doing
this with you all right I mean this is
this is fun and and like I said I should
have kept a journal my mom said to do it
but if I'd kept a lot of probably being
a two-year player and out had nothing to
a big in history obviously being in
Boston I met the Kennedys and uh
um uh just just so many cool guys I mean
you know they meet you like I tell guys
you know they're like hey on the mound I
go that's my job I was brought up that
way I take it very seriously like I said
I changed uh you know the you know when
I did it again jumping around here with
these questions but uh my sisters always
remind me that two days my mom sat at
the kitchen table with her hand when our
electricity got turned off so come on
guys so that's again that's why chasmine
you silver million no no no no no no do
your homework okay I said you know it
might have happened to something for
some but you know I didn't have a car in
high school I ran with my backpack from
my high school to our our town home and
uh so uh but to be able to meet some of
these people and you know they see you
and hey man you're funny they see me
DJing I go this stuff I love to do I'm
pitching I love it but again it was
about you know about winning because I'm
wearing a city on my chest I want to
perform you guys come get a dog and take
right from work take you know get your
beer and a dog I want there's nothing
worse driving home after I've laid an
egg I get knocked out in the third
inning I hate it but again like I told
the guys the other day in the clubhouse
I won 200 games because I was on with my
heater split the night I was on you had
no chance
the games that I got out of second and
third bases loaded and uh you know my
catchers are like you know after the
game like I have no idea how we did that
you know we won five to four but that's
what they pay you to do they pay you to
pitch I know going to bark when I wake
up I go through the lineup taking my
shower I go through the lineup you where
you guys prepare I mean this is fun for
me because you guys are bringing stuff
on me that I forgot about so it's it
makes it fun for me now
I wash my hair I'm going through the
lineup I know when I get to the stadium
in that game I'm gonna have second third
and one out somewhere in that game I
might have to get out of it to win the
game and uh so it's your mindset I go
through progressions like I said uh
physically I got you all the laps I ran
on backfields that nobody saw all the
Fielding I told the guys again in the
clubhouse I'll tell you guys I said you
know what your strengths are you polish
those but you freaking know what your
weaknesses are and just like in other
games I know what you do best I'm gonna
try and I'm gonna take that away from
you at the plate immediately
and especially when I pitch inside I
don't pitch inside the hit guys I pitch
inside to make a 17 inch plate a 24 inch
plate
I tell the pitchers that pitch inside
late it does nothing for you they're
going to climb right back on the plate I
pitch in early so when the guys are
still [__] around on the bench
spitting sunflower seeds the first
boom strike everybody talks about it
second Pitch boom inside light him up a
little bit everybody on the bench goes
oh oh [__] here we go here we go we got
a game so now you get guys attention and
and and you do your do your thing that
way but
I've met so many cool people I mean so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]